Is Mr. Jingles in heaven ?
Will Brooke get her revenge?
And where the f*ck is Bertie ?
All this and more tonight in our episode 8 breakdown !
Yes, we are on our final two episodes of American Horror Story and things seem to be falling in place for one of the most epic
Massacres of all time so let's get right into the story as we take a deep dive into the episode
We are one day before Halloween 1989
Which means one day before the giant camp Redwood festival
Brooke and Donna are at a diner having left crazy
Hitchhiker serial killer Bruce thumbless on the side of the road. It's kind of ironic
You know that the hitchhiker killer gets his thumbs chopped off.
I like it !
They are still on their mission of revenge to hunt down Margaret for being the mastermind behind both the
1970 and 1984 Camp Redwood massacres.
There's a great Crocodile Dundee reference
«That's a knife ! »
when Donna tells Brooke she's a final girl. If you want to know a little bit more about what a final girl is,
I talked about it in more detail in my episode 8 preview video
They're interrupted by a National Enquirer reporter by the name of Stacy Phillips
And if there's one thing we know about The Inquirer is that they'll stop at nothing for the truth
She's written books on killers such as Bundy and Dean and is now working on a new story about the massacres committed at Redwood by Jingles and Brooke
For her, the camp personifies everything wrong with the 80s. They excuse themselves with Brooke thinking they've been discovered.
As we all know, the world thinks Brooke is dead after Donna was able to fake her execution via lethal injection
Back at Camp Redwood, we're with the hitchhiker still caught in his never-ending death cycle
Imagine being stuck forever with a puka-shell necklace !
Mister«No thumbs» approaches in a sweet new ride and you know kids, always get in the car of a man wearing bloody bandages!
Bruce is also on his way to Redwood seeking revenge from Brooke and Donna who tied him up and left him for dead
He also has an obsession with increasing his kill count which will come in to play later on
Picking up the hitchhiker, we hear the muffled yells of someone in his trunk. These belong to a Mary Kay salesman.
Mary Kay being a popular brand of cosmetics
She was the one who saved Bruce, but he just ended up stabbing her and stealing her car
Using the cigarette lighter to cauterize his thumbs
My best guess here is that the stabbing occurred while in the Redwood property and that shall return as a ghost for the big massacre to come next episode
there is also a hint that Bruce has a split personality
When he opens the trunk to tell Mary Kay to shut up, mind you this is before he picks up the hitchhiker,
Notice no one in the passenger seat, he tells her we're trying to listen to Creedence.
In the subtitles and IMDB, Dillon McDermott's character is named Alex, but he introduces himself to Brooke and Donna in Episode seven as Bruce
So it's possible
These are the names of his dual personality
Margaret and Courtney observed the aftermath of Ricky's kajagoogoo slaughter with Ricky leaving his trademark pentagram and blood on the roof
Courtney is given the worst assistant job ever, having to cut up all the members of the band
Dispose of their bodies and clean up the bus before the big show. With so many people getting cut apart this episode,
It's no wonder why it's called «Rest In Pieces» while taking a garbage bag of goo out, he finds the band rehearsing
They too will be ready for the massacre. I haven't seen this many ghosts inside dated on tinder
Ricky stops a Billy Idol roadie who shows him Billy's silver jewelry
Now, Billy better be showing up next episode or this whole scene will be completely pointless because although fun,
It really doesn't give us any new information
In our next scene, Ricky air guitars - the Billy Idol's rebel yell
Which was released in 1983 and was ranked number 79 on vh1's top 100 hard rock songs of all time
Out of the blue, Jingles attacks who has sworn to kill Ricky to protect his son and avenge his wife
Ricky sees things differently telling jingles that he did him a favor
Jingles had lost his way. And this was to steer him back on track
Ricky is also pissed at jingles for essentially turning him in. He'll later tell Bruce that Jingles was responsible for
Offsetting the years of killing he had ahead of him
Remember, it was jingles who pointed out Ricky that ended up with his arrest.
Their fight is cut short however, when Bruce slams into Jingles killing him
But Bruce is more interested in Ricky, one of his idols even calling him an inspiration
Bruce wants the opportunity to work with a legend and asked if he can help track Jingles, something
Ricky will take him up on after they use his satanic powers to track Jingles down
Now, I really hope there's some sort of Apocalypse tie-in here
We've gone through all these episodes and Ricky's relationship with Satan hasn't really been explored
It's just like he has his power and it's never really talked about
Back at the motel, Stacey knocks on Brooke and Donna's room telling them she knows who they really are
She's been studying Redwood for years and even paid the warden, $1500
to get the VHS of Donna at Brookes execution. That's like the amount of money, I'd pay for Xavier sex tape
Instead of turning them in, Stacey agrees to let them go if they can provide her with a better
story and Brooke and Donna agree. Stacy will drive them into Redwood and in return, they'll show her the
Locations where all the murders happen as well as try to prove that Margaret was behind it all.
Jingles resurrects telling the hitchhiker that he felt it all, but the scariest thing that hitchhiker mentions, is that every time you die
It's as if pieces of you go missing and that's the last thing jingles wants he can't forget why he's here in the first place
his son
He needs to kill Ramirez and end it all for good
Trevor has hooked up with Montana with the VIP cabin experience
Remember if you pay some extra cash, you can stay in the actual cabins where the massacres occurred
Very romantic !
Montana reiterates her plan to massacre everyone at the festival in order to draw paranormal
Investigators who may be able to help her from this purgatory
She wants anything but to be stuck at Redwood forever
Trevor is in love with her and as we'll find out later,
will do anything to be with her.
Margaret watches Trevor kissing Montana from far
Remember they are married and she's gonna be pissed
My guess is that Trevor will die next episode and it will be Margaret who does the deed
The bromance between Ricky and Bruce intensifies as they continue their hunt for Jingles when Xavier offers to help
After all, it was jingles who put him in that oven in episode four
He takes them to his body when Jingles attacks and kills Xavier
Jingles tells Ricky he killed himself
But since Jingles can no longer leave Redwood. Ricky threatens to go to Alaska and kill his son Bobby as a final act of revenge
This tilts Jingles
Who is then shot by
Margaret needing the help of both Ricky and Bruce for her final plan
Brooke and Donna takes Stacy where Brooke was strung up in episode four,
but she ain't buying the story
For her though, it doesn't matter telling a story that sells does
Brooke is about to kill Stacy when she's stopped by Donna
But she says if she went through with it, she become just like Margaret and Jingles.
Jingles and Margaret became killers because they fed their hate and anger
If they can get revenge without hurting another innocent soul
Stacy runs into Ricky, Margaret and Bruce but already knows too much and is killed.
Margaret divulges her plan that she wants to do something that has purpose
Remember she owns and has profited of properties once owned by serial killers creating bed-and-breakfast for thrill-seekers and haunted house enthusiastics visits
if they can kill all these famous bands,
It will attract hundreds of their fans to pay homage and stay at camp redwood making her a fortune
As long as Billy Idol isn't killed
Trevor says he wants to kill himself to spend eternity with Montana, but she ain't about that
She's down and out because she was outed for bringing Ricky to the camp
She also exposes the double standard of men's serial killers being revered while women always get blamed for making them that way
She says she's irredeemable
But Trevor tells her she can change Montana lets him go. I mean come on. Mr
Shue is in love with you and he has an elephant trunk. You're a psycho. Now, this is the scene
I really want to talk about. There are a ton of unanswered questions
here and I want to hear what you guys think in the comments below but I'm gonna lay out all the facts and theories so
You can decide for yourself what's really happening?
It starts with Xavier and the two pranksters stabbing jingles by the dock and setting the rowboat out into the middle of the lake
So he can bleed out and die. The same lake where his younger brother died years ago
This really sucks for Jingles because if he dies, that's just more time he's wasting when he could be out searching for Ricky
So he doesn't end up killing his son. Now, there's nothing really out of the ordinary here with the boys telling Jingles
He'll die a slow death than just resurrect again as normal
But I want you to pay attention to some key lines of dialogue like one of the pranksters saying
What someone does help him and he does achieve peace. As he apologizes to Bobby in a rowboat,
He sees Montana by the water now. She's either here for one of two reasons
one because this scene is an homage to Friday the 13th sending and she's here to act as a
stand-in for the police in that version or two -- and this is more conspiracy theory --
If Montana was there and saw jingles being taken away by Bobby
will it provide some sort of key to how the ghosts can get out? If Jingles like some argue makes it to heaven at the
End of this episode, does the lake and/or Bobby provide some clue as if some sort of portal to the other side
Jingles awakens with young Bobby in front of him and is taken to Lavinia
Remember she's been searching for Bobby for decades and only now has finally found him. All the clues point to this not being Camp Redwood
Even though you can make it one of the cabins in the background. The first thing Jingles asks is where he is
which for a guy who has spent years at Redwood should be able to know every inch of that place but again he could just
Be foggy since memory loss seems to be a side effect from resurrecting. The second clue is Lavinia's demeanor
She's all of a sudden kind and forgiving. To her, Jingles has made some sort of quote ultimate sacrifice
Which has somehow brought back Bobby.
Lavinia tells them they're a family here. And this is where he can find peace
But remember what that prankster said
You're never gonna find peace,
Not while you're here. Jingles is then posed with a question from his brother to stay with them. If they're already dead at camp Redwood
This is an odd question since he'd have no choice but to stay with them
Bobby even says to Jingles that if he stays, no one would be able to hurt him here
Is that because he has powers or is it because they are?
Someplace different than where the others are
also
There's this whole question. If Bobby was at the center of the curse
Does that mean that curse is now over? And the episode ends with
Jingles playing with Bobby and the ducks the ending mixed with the music really
Feeling like this is the end of jingles story that he has redeemed
Himself and ended up with his family in some sort of heaven, his soul finally at rest. So will we see jingles again?
I can't help but think yes, even though in the preview video
He's not shown at all if this is indeed a way to the afterlife
It should provide a clue for how the campers can get out and Jingles might be that link between the two worlds
I posed this question on the HS subreddit and user
Verdigris speech had an interesting theory that the lake could act as some sort of portal
Meaning jingles could go back and warn the others to avert the massacre
Saving all the 80s bands we know and love there are so many different ways
This could go from here and I want to hear your theories and comments below
I'll be coming out with a preview video which has a ton of juicy details in it for the next episode
So make sure you're subscribe and stab that like button while you're at it
You can also follow me on twitter Epting story YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very much